guys so we're down to the end of season
three here so like two episodes to go
so i'm going to ask you both for your
best teas yeah josh what can you tease
about the last two episodes of the
season
oh uh just wait it is
a train that doesn't stop it is heart
pounding as equally as it is
heartbreaking
and by the end of the finale in season
three
it's a game changer it changes
everything
completely wow
perfume you get some add to that
what did you say earlier josh fever and
fever
it yes forever fervor
it's just going to be very it's a it's a
heartbreaking very
dark cliffhanger ending yeah
um and it is um i think everyone is
just for the characters i think it's
going to be
where do we go from here right yeah i
mean your character's been through like
a lot of
i guess turmoil drama yeah like what's
up in like the play
oh so fun so fun yeah as an accurate
so it's like meat on a bone you know and
when you have
things uh trauma like that to play it's
it's you have just a lot to chew on it i
don't know why i'm making a meat analogy
but
you know it works but you know that's
what it is
it's just there's a lot there to play
with and um it's been
it's just really cool that they trust me
enough to do it so i'm
always just happy to do it right
now we as viewers don't know about
season four i know you guys aren't going
to tell me do you guys know
if you're a new person for it you guys
don't even know we don't have season
four
we don't know the end we don't know the
ultimate answer to the mystery we have
no idea you know
that's something that we set up from the
very beginning that it was
something we wanted kept from us so
we're kind of discovering it
in real time almost with you guys uh at
home
and uh i don't know it makes it all the
more exciting
yeah yeah i mean yeah josh like we've
seen a few shows like this this season
that kind of
they're just kind of gone and don't get
to wrap up their story so
if this was the end would you be
satisfied would
viewers be satisfied no that could be
really bad no okay
they will be really mad
they will be really mad if it ends uh if
it
ends at the after the finale of season
three
uh because the possibilities of where it
goes
after this are sort of
endless and exciting and uh
have to be seen um it the story
is by no means over um it's somehow
in in some ways just beginning yeah
what's it like to be in that kind of
limbo like you don't know because you
shot the finale right you can't change
anything
yeah oh yeah well that's i mean as an
actor you just kind of have to get
used to that you know what i mean um but
being in this is vodka don't know man
you just gotta stay hopeful
you know ultimately what's meant to
happen will happen but you can
you just hope that you can continue to
tell the story and
we've invested now three years three
seasons of our lives playing these
characters and it's you wanna
you know see them through to the end and
i think
that's definitely um
that's a gift as an actor for us to have
that experience of
living a character from beginning all
the way to finish because you're right
there are shows that just get canceled
and you kind of just have to let it go
and that can be hard but
you just got to stay hopeful yeah yeah i
don't
i don't think any of us are ready to say
goodbye to
these characters we're also so close to
close as well like as a cast we're all
we're all really close which is
kind of a bonus as well yeah yeah now
josh i noticed on twitter i didn't
really notice watching the show
but a lot of fans point out like your
your glasses
so like when it's like when something
like like profound like we're
thinking with something that glasses
come off like it's not been a conscious
choice
because people are talking with this on
twitter i mean i think
it's now become something that i'm uh
you know aware of because so many people
have uh commented on his uh on his
glasses
which are you know great frames by the
way i mean i i i kind of understand it
but uh yeah i mean i think you know
he's a man who needs those glasses to
see uh
technology and anything sort of in in a
digital way
uh so he puts those on and you know i
think it's just kind of become
part of him it's like a little tick
almost yeah
it's fun yeah i think he he he's got
little ticks and i think that's one of
them yeah
and parveen i mean i love how um open
you are about
having adhd like why has that been
something that's been so important to
you to
put out there
fine when i found out i always say i i
when i found out that i had adhd is
when i started the journey of accepting
myself and starting to like myself
because it was it gave me an answer to a
lot of things that i
didn't have an answer to of of things
that i struggled with and once
once i was able to find that out and do
the research it's almost like i flipped
it on its head and
embraced it and now it's like my
favorite thing about me is that i have
adhd so yeah it changed my life you know
finding out about it what kind of
feedback have you gotten for being so
public about it i even on manifest i've
had like maybe a good four
five six different people say i think i
have adhd like i watched your videos
like when you speak about it i think i
also have it and i'm
it's i get messages all the time about
it um
and it's it's just really cool that
the thing that i thought was so
embarrassing or the thing that i thought
was
always holding me back or why i wasn't
here in my life or further along is
now the thing that's actually helping
people
you know it's it's kind of given me this
new purpose in a in a way
um and it's just it's just really cool i
never thought that i would have
something to say about
that you know what i mean i don't know
how to describe it like something bigger
than myself
you know and that i feel very lucky yeah
that's a beautiful thing
yeah so josh what was it like i'm
assuming you guys shot season three like
throughout the last year like
pandemic so what was it like
production-wise like trying to navigate
this new world
i mean we were one of the first shows
that came back and started filming
during you know sort of peak pandemic in
the united states anyway um you know
i i've always said that there's no more
adaptable group than a group of
filmmakers and
we're able to sort of adjust and pivot
and and
and figure it out you know to do the
thing that we love and we love to tell
this story and and
it was definitely different and there
was definitely some learning curves and
a lot of protocols
you know put in place on set with
testing and
and zones you know you know certain
departments could only stay in one zone
and the actors
you know had a real group of trust
with one another you know that we wanted
to keep each other safe so we weren't
doing
crazy things outside of work you know we
weren't going to
you know uh underground raves or
anything like that
so we were keeping each other safe and
looking after each other and
you know telling the story and by the
second week i think it felt like
it was normal you know it was a normal
way to work we were on a roll and we
were into it and
so much so so much so that i think it's
going to be strange going back to how we
use the phone
right yeah what was it like for you
you know i feel like all the it was such
a small
price to pay in terms of you know
testing and like
it's such a small price to pay and in
the grand scheme of things to be able to
go back to work you know there there are
so many people that
don't have that or didn't have that and
to be able to go back to work to be able
to
you know see your colleagues and be
around people again all you know the
protocols all that it was
you know it was just a small price to
pay it never felt like such a huge
burden because you're just so
grateful to be working and you're so
grateful to be telling the story so
you know it was fine you know
i mean what we do is such a privilege
anyway but to do it at that moment in
time in history in the world
felt uh somehow even more um
more special yeah yeah yeah that's the
thing parveen like have you found
either personally professionally like
your perspective has kind of
changed on things after what we've been
through over the last year or so
i you know what i realized that i got to
move to wyoming
i kind of i really like being by myself
i really liked you know i always say
like if people
didn't have to suffer i really enjoyed
kind of the solitude you know because i
s it allowed me to reflect on
who i am as a person and the things that
i want to
um put forward and where i want to be in
my life and the person that i want to be
it kind of gave me a minute to think on
all those things and you know i
i really appreciated that aspect but a
lot of people
really suffered during this time and and
for them i wanted to go back to normal
as soon as possible
you know but for me personally i i like
the solitude you know i've um
because of my adhd everything is so
chaotic all the time so
the world is just full of distractions
for someone like me and so for the world
to kind of shut down
i was able to center myself which is not
a opportunity
i mean when are you ever in a pandemic
you don't ever get to have that
experience but again too many people are
suffering
to keep it that way you know we got to
get we got to get back to normal you
know for other people
because i think that's a lot like
manifest i think these characters are
sort of
being forced into a situation where they
have to
look at who they are and how they
navigate the world and how they
connect with other people and how they
um
you know how they show their humanity
towards one another and i think
uh i think what happened to these
passengers these callings are sort of
asking
uh these these characters to
ask themselves that question you know
they've been given this second chance
and
what are you going to do with it and how
are you going to navigate the world this
time
yeah yeah i mean speaking of interaction
i mean you guys have an amazing fan base
on the show very vocal
fanbase so what is that like to have
that interaction have that feedback from
the fans that yeah i've carried you
through
three seasons and hopefully more
well we were just talking someone just
put out a 46 page
like josh called it a manifest i keep
calling it a dissertation
of what they think the show is and what
it means and
that's like that's passion that's that's
that's who we that's why we do it you
know this is this is the art of
storytelling it we
we wouldn't be able to tell a story
unless we had fans unless we had an
audience we wouldn't be here
um if it wasn't for them tuning in every
week
you know so that's it's it's really cool
uh josh it's the best you know having
fans that are that vocal that's
passionate that's smart
is the best i mean it just makes
the uh the process of making it even
more enjoyable because as parveen said
you know we make it for them
and uh the fact that they're the fact
that they're so engaged
in something that we're making is
uh icing on the cake yeah it's all you
could
it's all you could hope for and want
yeah absolutely well
i can't wait to see season four i'll
just say that okay
[Music]
us too thank you